aujourd'hui on parle de raccourcis
clavier pour final cut pro 10 et vous
allez voir que ça peut vous faire gagner
un temps monumental des raccourcis que
vous connaissiez peut-être pas et ça on
en parle après l'intro et salut à tous
les amis c'est françois pour la chaîne
explique moi encore ça me fait super
plaisir de vous retrouver aujourd'hui
pour un nouveau tuto sur final cut pro
10 aujourd'hui on part deux raccourcis
clavier alors des raccourcis clavier sur
final cut il en existe des tonnes des
tonnes des tonnes d'ailleurs vous pouvez
tous les liens sur le site d'apple ou
même dans final cut il ya une un listing
de tous les raccourcis qu'il ya moi
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'eux
avait dit préférer de ce que j'utilise
le plus souvent et qui me font gagner
énormément de temps je vais vous
partager mes petites astuces de montage
et sans plus attendre
on y va c'est parti direction alors le
premier raccourci c'est un raccourci qui
va me servir à élaguer un petit peu mes
plans à enlever toutes les zones où il
n'ya rien où je parle pas tous les
blancs grosso modo qu'il ya dans mes
ruches
alors ce que je pourrais faire ici par
exemple n'y a pas de blanc mais ce que
je pourrais faire c'est tout simplement
appuyé sur la touche b pour sortir
l'outil rasoir et découpé et ensuite
appuyez sur la touche à et supprimer
cette partie je pourrais faire ça je
pourrais également utilisé comme en mai
mettra landreau je vous couper ce qui
m'évite d'avoir à sortir l'outil rasoir
et avoir la même chose mais il ya une
solution beaucoup plus rapide quand on a
des roches long ou beaucoup plus de
choses il ya des fois j'ai jusqu'à 30
minutes de rushes à élaguer donc ça fait
beaucoup et c'est un petit peu long
entre guillemets de sortir l'outil de
revenir tout le temps alors moi ce que
je fais c'est j'utilise la touche r qui
va me donner cet outil ici qui va me
permettre de sélectionner une zone 6 et
du blanc hop je supprime ici pareil et
comme ça ça me permet d'élaguer dans un
premier temps tout le gros tout le
déchet en fait tous les blancs et après
je pourrai laguë plus finement soit avec
l'outil rasoir soit tout simplement en
rognant les bords mais cet outil là bas
pour dégrossir le travail au départ il
est vraiment cool
il fait gagner énormément de temps
deuxième raccourci super intéressant
quand par exemple on a appliqué
plusieurs effets sur un plan et que au
final on se rend compte que c'est pas du
tout ce qu'on voulait on a envie
de dégager un petit peu tous les effets
qui étaient déjà là et pour ça il ya une
solution très simple je vais
sélectionner mon plan et je pourrais
éventuellement décoché pour enlever les
effets pour qu'il ne s'affiche pas mêlé
décoché ça ne les supprime pas ils sont
toujours là la solution la plus simple
c'est de faire un command shift x et si
je pouvoir enlever soient tous les
effets parce que par défaut ils sont
tous sélectionnés soit je pouvoir
enlever un seul effet ou deux effets
juste ce que j'ai envie d'enlever si par
exemple c'est juste le réglage de
couleur qui me convient pas si je vais
le supprimer si je veux reprendre à zéro
là par exemple je peux juste supprimer
le réglage de couleur troisième
raccourci super utile surtout si vous
captez comme moi l'audio séparément de
la vidéo
eh ben ça va être les plans groupés un
plan groupe et ça va vous permettre de
regrouper justement différents éléments
ça peut être des images ça peut être de
la vidéo ça peut être du son dans un
seul plein comme ça vous n'aurez plus
qu'une seule gamme d'effets à y
appliquer par exemple ça peut être très
pratique et en déplaçant le plan groupe
est uniquement n'aura pas besoin de
déplacer plusieurs éléments alors pour
faire ça c'est très simple on va
sélectionner les deux plans qui sont ici
et faire options ou alt
j'ai failli le coach me propose même de
nommer ce plan dont contours qui est est
tout simplement up et si jamais basse
finalement ce groupement de plans ne
convenait pas si je me suis trompé ou si
en fin de compte je me rends compte que
c'est pas utile
bah on va sélectionner ce plan groupe et
on va faire un command shift j'ai et je
retrouve tous mes plans indépendante
comme il était haut du parc quatrième
raccourcis clavier un truc qui est assez
intéressant quand on veut faire des
arrêts sur image c'est la fonctionnalité
prendre une photo je vais tout
simplement mettre à l'endroit où je veux
prendre ma photo ici où je veux mettre
un arrêt sur image je vais appuyer sur
option f
et ici je me retrouve avec trois
secondes 2 photo fix up crack bloqués
voilà pour du sport pour des titrages ça
peut être super intéressant numéro 5 un
raccourci que j'aime beaucoup que
j'utilise énormément c'est la rampe de
vélocité ça vous permettre de faire des
accélérations ou des ralentis progressif
alors tout simplement on va se mettre à
l'endroit où on veut aller ici par
exemple je vais faire un shift bay est
comme ça je vais pouvoir ajuster
si une partie rapide une partie lente
par exemple ici on va mettre la rapide
pourrait vite par exemple et à voir ces
petits effets up de transition de
ralentis d'accélérer tout d'un coup mais
relativement fluide quand même elle fera
d'ailleurs une vidéo très prochainement
sur les rampes de vélocité parce que ça
peut servir à plein de choses à des
effets à des transitions mais ça on en
parlera très bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo ralenti bat pas super connu et qui
pourtant est ultra pratique est ultra
simple quand on a besoin de remettre sa
timeline tout entière qu'on puisse la
voir la visualiser dans sa globalité
tout simplement on va faire shift z est
comme ça je peux voir toute ma timeline
ce qui est quand même relativement
pratique plutôt que de zoomer dézoomer
pour avoir la bonne taille etc
des fois c'est trop ce qu'il faut c'est
de passer un autre de réglages qui vous
faire gagner énormément de temps c'est
la copie des réglages sur différents
grrrr
alors que vous pouvez voir moi je t'ai
tout ma colorimétrie mes réglages sur un
ajustement nucléaire d'ailleurs on en a
parlé ici c'est vachement pratique mais
ça n'empêche que j'ai parfois voire même
souvent ont besoin d'étalonner les plans
les en fonction des autres pour
l'exposition pour la saturation et
l'idée c'est de pouvoir coller les
réglages qu'on aura pris sur un plan de
référence sur tous les autres alors pour
ça on va sélectionner le plan qui nous
intéresse ici c'est celui là je vais
faire un petit commencé comme si je
voulais copier le plan tout simplement
le dupliquer ensuite je vais
sélectionner et pas tous les autres qui
m'intéresse est là au lieu de faire un
command vecchi copierait simplement le
plan je vais faire commandes shift v et
ici j'ai cette boîte de dialogue qui
s'ouvre avec la possibilité alors là y'a
que des réglages couleurs mais ça peut
être tout un tas d'autres règles elles
la possibilité de copier tous les
réglages du plan de départs ou une
partie certain justin juste 2 juste ce
que vous voulez et ses réglages vont
s'appliquer sur tous les autres plans
n'y aura pas besoin de refaire plan par
plan tous les réglages ça c'est plutôt
cool quand même un point faut avouer
notre raccourci très très pratique que
j'ai mis beaucoup de temps à trouver sur
final cut c'était un peu pénible sur
première c'est quand même vachement
facile et sur final cut c'est un peu
plus compliqué à trouver allez savoir
pourquoi
c'est la balance automatique des blancs
pour ça je vais sélectionner le plan qui
m'intéresse ici
je vais faire commandes halte options et
b et beaumont à notre balance des blancs
automatique qui s'est fait et ça c'est
plutôt intéressante parce que sinon il
faut aller dans les routes couleurs pour
batailler sur la température et ça prend
du temps alors que là on a un petit
raccourci clavier qui nous fait ça de
suite
on est presque au bout l'avant-dernier
raccourci c'est un raccourci qui est
vachement sympa parce qu'il va nous
permettre de gérer la vitesse des
différentes plantes plutôt que d'aller
ici sur cette icône et gérait ensuite
personnalisés etc
on va tout simplement cliquer sur notre
plan appuyez sur commande
r et ici vous voyez on a la vitesse qui
s'affiche et je vais pouvoir
alors soit prendre ici des vitesses
prédéfinis qui sont là soit tout
simplement aller chercher le coin et
accélérer ou ralentir mon plat et ça mis
bout à bout ça fait quand même pas mal
de temps de gagner plutôt que d'aller
cliquer sur le bouton à chaque fois et
enfin dernière à courre site est très
simple puisque justement si on utilise
beaucoup les raccourcis clavier on va
pas forcément avoir envie d'aller
chercher sa souris donc on va vouloir se
déplacer dans la timeline de manière un
petit peu plus rapide alors on va
utiliser les flèches pour ça si on
avance d'une flèche ou si on recule on
avance d'une image ce qui peut être
quand même relativement long si on veut
avancer dans le projet de manière fluide
si j'appuie tout simplement sur la
touche shift et avec les flèches
je vais cette fois ci me déplacer de 10
images ce qui va me permettre d'avancer
beaucoup plus vite et d'affiner ensuite
avec juste la touche flèche sans shift
jusque là touche flèche c'est dur à dire
c'est juste la touche
laich et donc vous allez pouvoir vous
déplacer dans votre timeline de manière
beaucoup plus rapide sans avoir à
utiliser la souris
et voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu j'espère que ces
raccourcis vont vous aider à monter plus
vite
n'hésitez pas à mettre le traditionnel
coup deux blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui se situe juste en dessous de cette
vidéo si vous avez d'autres raccourcis
clavier que vous utiliser au quotidien
n'hésitez pas à nous les partager dans
les commentaires ça fait toujours
plaisir moyenne tellement que forcément
j'ai dû passer à côté mais c'étaient les
raccourcis que je préférais que
j'utilise le plus souvent que je voulais
vous montrer et puis comme d'habitude
surtout surtout surtout rester curieux
et à très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo
[Musique]